Westfield Gibbs gives up San Francisco
Mall signaling more pain ahead retailers
have been fleeing the city's downtown
and some analysts say there may be more
to come it's an issue facing various
downtowns around the United States I
love how they try and once again
obviously what's going on it's it's
affecting everyone yeah no um the Hilton
and park 55 massive hotels in Center San
Francisco being surrendered to lenders
and a massive Mall which is several
hundred thousand square feet being
surrendered is particularly unique to
San Francisco maybe it's all of the
human feces littered about the streets
or the rampant open-air drug use but
this city has been gutted and destroyed
and the question to ask is
should we be happy or sad about this
should we glout haha look what your
policies have wrought why even though
these policies are destroying these
cities you still have these liberals
cheering for it so maybe we just say
okay then you're getting what you want I
suppose they are I I still think there's
reason to be sad about it because this
is something that is being destroyed by
people who didn't build it and that's
always very important to remember this
city was built up by their parents and
grandparents and great-grandparents and
then they came along and they tore it
down and part of the reason they tore it
down was out of Envy there are people
who have worked harder than me who have
made more beautiful things than I've
made or could even hope to make or am
interested in making and that makes me
mad and I want to rip it all apart and
so when they start to do that by
implementing insane policies that say
things like you can steal and we won't
prosecute you as long as it's less than
nine hundred dollars worth of theft
that's occurred
and you rewire people's thinking into
this very insane short-term
um Paradigm that rewards people for
taking and not for making then this is
the exact scenario you end up with you
get destruction and nobody builds
anything why would they you've only
punished them for it can we go back to
when they passed that that law in San
Francisco where they were like or I
don't know if it was a law or a policy
or whatever anything under 990 or
whatever you would not be criminally
charged if you stole and then we
immediately started seeing videos of
people filling garbage bags full of
merchandise well I guess because none of
them none of those items equal up to a
thousand dollars so they would just
start dumping entire shelves into bags
hop on their bike and then ride out and
everyone just shrugs why wouldn't these
people keep doing this
if they get arrested they get let out a
couple hours later and they can go right
back and they do this 20 times yep and
then when I have these employees at
Lululemon who reported on or tried to
stop the things they just filmed it they
just filmed it yeah and they got fired
yeah just for filming because the
policies don't intervene they went
outside like father I'm filming or
something like that well right I've
mentioned this a hundred times in the
show but anytime someone's doing
something degenerate immoral or
destructive we have to engage in every
level of social economic analysis to
excuse their behavior they were only
stealing from that store because we
didn't spend enough public money on the
library in their neighborhood or they
didn't have a good enough public school
but then when these people filmed
someone who's stealing something from
their store which is an abundantly
reasonable reaction to people committing
an act of theft in front of you they're
evil they have to be fired there's no
mercy we don't engage in any kind of
analysis of their behavior we just
dispense with them you look at AOC
cheering or or demanding the criminal
Char the charges for for Penny saying
that oh it was murder so a murder
happened in public how is he not getting
it's it's wild they're creating the
problem they're exacerbating the crime
and then they're trying to imprison and
destroy the lives of anybody who tries
to protect themselves they genuinely
don't want you living in these cities
and where does this all come from
we have communism being rebranded yep in
Western culture yeah a lot of this stems
back to Karl Marx it's the same policies
it's the theory that there is class
Warfare there's an oppressor class and
there are the oppressed and a lot of
people
when you're talking about this with
normal people it's not probably good to
talk about communism because they look
at you sideways like you have a hole in
your head and you're some conspiracy
theorist
but Marxism
has been rebranded to be equity and up
in Canada where I'm from we even have
the conservative leaders calling for an
equitable Society well Equity is just a
quality of outcome that's not what we
want we want a quality of opportunity if
Martin Luther King were alive today
they'd be calling him
the black face of white supremacy just
as they did with Larry Elder in
California because he was calling for
equality of opportunity but he would be
aghast at what's happening today I mean
but we're also talking about the Civil
Rights era back in the 50s and stuff so
he's fairly conservative on a lot of
issues and uh I I don't know what his
his religious background was obviously
Martin Luther King yeah obviously he's
Christian but I don't know which which
sex is Baptist Baptist yeah I mean just
that alone makes him a fascist right a
crystal fascist right if you're a
Christian today you're a crystal fascist
I get called it all the time people
assume I'm a Christian I'm not I'm
basically agnostic
but I deal with these crazy people all
the time these violent people I've been
arrested twice after getting assaulted
just because it's easier to get rid of
me than it is to get rid of all the
crazy people I've been saying that we
had a um press for truth Dan Dix was at
a was that a protest do you know the
story that's me that he was filming oh
he was filming you and then they they
pulled him I'm the guy that got
assaulted and then they removed him they
said you got to get out of here and they
pulled him out and threatened him with
the rest that's happened to him as well
right they he was confused because he
was recently just interviewing me when I
was assaulted and then they threatened
you with the rest or did arrest you no
they the main police officer who was
there to investigate a previous assault
that already incurred smiled as I was
getting assaulted wow and this video had
80 million views it went all around the
world wow Dan was just a couple months
ago but I've also been arrested after
getting assaulted twice in Vancouver uh
Dan was filming a protest they attacked
him the police then come in and they say
you have to leave and he's like me he's
like they attacked me and he's like
don't care you get out now or you're
gonna get arrested it happened it
happened I've been telling people it
happens to Street Preachers as well in
Canada the police the police are going
well look at that preacher in um in
writing Pennsylvania do you see the
story no there was a pride event
happening and a guy was in the street
and he just he started to quote a Bible
verse and the cop just grabbed someone
arrested oh I did see that because the
cops are thinking it is easier to arrest
one person than deal with a riot that's
right yeah yeah absolutely but it's good
it's great when they do that because
this backfires
backfires every time I got charged with
causing a disturbance after getting
assaulted by a union rep actually of the
British Columbia government
and I was hoping it would go to trial
because this would have been a slam dunk
Victory but of course one day before my
course hearing the charge gets dismissed
nah in the meantime I was banned from
walking on all these streets in the
middle of downtown Vancouver
but all it does is bring in more support
for the cause so it backfires every time
and we have to I mean we have to expose
this every time but we have to also take
it and use it in our favor
as we have been doing and it's working
people are waking up finally to what's
going on in Western culture yeah you
just worry though and I think there's
kind of in intellectual and governmental
arms race occurring which is the left is
trying to become as powerful as possible
and get as much leverage over the
average person before people wake up to
what's happening right ideally for them
everyone hasn't woken up to what they're
doing and what they're trying to do
until it's already too late and they
have all of the Power so we have to get
as many people as possible informed
before we get to the point where they're
literally able to do whatever they want
and it's getting close I mean it really
is getting very close and my biggest
concern for all of this is the
universities because that's where these
kids are really getting indoctrinated
yeah yes a lot of them have left as
parents or whatever but they get into
these universities and these are
indoctrination stations now I disagree
okay I think it's tick tock
I think it's Val for sure yeah it's in
high schools too gradually for the
younger kids I think kids are starting
to to push back but I think you know
I've had this debate with uh Dr Peter
bagosian who shares a similar view to
yours that this this stuff originates in
universities and I think a component of
it does but I think social media
algorithms have perpetuated this the
reason why we're seeing so many
companies now backtrack and panic even
like you know everyone's saying oh ESG
is driving this stuff and I'm like I
don't think so I think this stuff is
driving ESG or there's some correlation
but not a direct causation Target saying
they wanted to hide their pride
merchandise in some stores the bottom
line is everything and if their cost
benefit analysis is we make money when
we do Pride stuff they'll keep doing it
now that the Bud Light thing happened
they're starting to say we actually are
going to lose a lot of money if we do
this so just stop doing it what's the
point so I think that's actually a very
promising sign I do think there's
something turning around here and I
think we are on a major path towards
victory yeah I've been hearing some
crazy stuff like people who are
completely outside of politics posting
things on YouTube and stuff and saying
like hey man I'm not cool with this
people are repeat me well no it was me
yeah well yeah what is it I used to be
in the investment Arena I used to have a
real job before I was a crazy billboard
person standing out on the street
getting assaulted and arrested but crazy
bill it amazed Me That Wall Street
essentially was captured by communism
because that's as capitalist as you get
yet we have ESG coming through the back
door and you mentioned ESG and
why is ESG capturing Wall Street well
ultimately that even comes down to
communism because you have firms like
BlackRock managing this 30 billion
dollar pension fund or whatever it is in
California
and you get the leftist politicians
pressuring BlackRock that if you don't
start pushing our agenda we're not going
to let you manage our gigantic pension
fund
so ultimately
they bow down to some of these pressures
and they start in turn putting these
pressures on the companies that they
invest in otherwise they won't invest in
them
and when it comes to investing it's all
about the institutional investors that
these corporations care about they don't
care about the retail investor it's all
about the institutions and so kind of
through this back door they've gotten in
there but all this is coming from so
many directions it's the weft it's the
who it's the U.S well I mean the
activist organizations exist but what I
see happening is
when
it was about what's socially acceptable
and what's not before the internet
racism is not socially acceptable
any like most bigotry hates speech on
stuff people are like hey we don't want
to do that because it can cost us money
if I'm selling Donuts in my donut shop
the last thing we want is for someone to
feel unwelcome to stop buying from us
that simple component along with the
1964 Civil Rights Act which enshrined
civil rights created algorithmic
pressures you end up with social media
running two different worlds right away
one was nationalistic one was
Progressive
the progressive one seemed to be more
socially acceptable because it was in
line with movies in Hollywood and things
like that the nationalistic one seemed
to be conservative so it's no good so
what do they do
Facebook almost immediately starts
having conservative stories pulled from
their trending news tab that was the big
the big breaking Revelation from Gizmodo
then they start from like 2007 2008
start actively promoting as much as
possible things that were socially
acceptable
so companies started mass producing
articles that just played the social
justice game right because that's what
was getting promoted and that's what
made them money
so if you've got a kid who's nine years
old in 2009
and they just get on Facebook for the
first time even though that's what
you're supposed to be 13. but let's say
they their parent got him a cell phone
and they found a way to get on it all
they see every day are videos of black
people being beaten by police why
because it made money for corporations
that's the only reason media websites
made money off of it that kid nine years
old it's only thing he sees
now he's 23. his whole world growing up
the only thing he ever saw was these
kinds of videos
then you end up with that video where it
was Nuance Pro I don't know if you saw
this one Nuance bro is having a Twitter
space with this gen Z for change guy and
the Gen Z for change guy said 30 percent
of black people are killed each year
like just by the police
a number so insane Nuance Pro is like
that means all black people would be
dead in three three years or so are you
nuts and then he the kid goes would you
agree that 15 to 20 is more is more fair
and then they're just dying laughing
like have you lost your mind no they
never had it
that's why long story short I think it's
the algorithms that are manipulating
these kids into believing this
fictitious version of the world and then
you end up with a lot of people saying
they're delusional or they're crazy and
I'm like no no no no no there's a
difference someone may be suffering a a
disability a an ailment developmental uh
disability is absolutely different from
a kid growing up and being lied to their
whole life yes the problem with society
today so we think we're this Advanced
Society I said this on a video the other
day that took off a little bit when
talking about the transition to kids
we think we're this Advanced Society
technologically and all that we are yet
psychologically we're the same as
cavemen used to be our minds are very
malleable we're prone to group think
we're prone to mass psychosis
and now you bring in social media and
these algorithms and it's so easy to
manipulate vast swaths of the population
and that is what's happening and you say
this isn't necessarily coming from the
universities but all these people
working at these social media companies
a lot of them became radicalized and got
pushed further left while they were
going to University and then they get
these jobs Facebook was built at a
university by Mark Zuckerberg while he
was at the University but why is it in
you know pre-2016 you uh Twitter is the
Free Speech wing of the Free Speech
party and then all of a sudden it starts
to change that I think may have been the
result of the election of Donald Trump
you see that video where Google
executives are crying saying I can't
believe we let this happen and things
like that why is it that in the early
days of these uh uh these these websites
these media companies that were getting
traction the one I often cite is
mike.com which is you know woke
Progressive when it started it was Ron
Paul libertarian because it wasn't and
these are the same people who went to
University who started these companies
at the time held very different views
and then it changed I think the reason
is over a long enough period of time if
the pressure is on conservative view bad
liberal view good then you end up with
hyperpolarization towards the liberal
and the Banning of conservative ideas I
don't think there's anything to do do
with universities universities
theoretically should take generations to
indoctrinate a society you you're there
for a few years you come out and then
you're you're dumped right back into
society spending a few years in an
induction indoctrination Center you come
out you have those ideas you try to then
apply that pressure to the rest of the
country which is millions hundreds of
millions of people you may you will hold
those views but it's not going to be as
pronounced because you can only go so
far thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time